foreign
I am mayank and welcome to this amazing
video on how to become an AI solution
Architect by simply learn but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these type
of videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our YouTube channel as we
bring you the best videos daily also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any update
from Simply learn so let's get started
in the dynamic field of artificial
intelligence the role of AI solution
architect has emerged as a critical and
soft after position insufficient
planning unsuitable architecture and
inability to scale are common causes of
failure of AI projects these AI
professional with the gap between
Cutting Edge AI technology and real
world business challenges crafting
Innovative solution that drives success
organization are always look out for the
AI architecture to Aid in the formation
of architectural strategy the
development of operation and the
identification of the tools and feature
in this video we will discuss what it
takes to become an AI solution architect
their duties how much they earn and how
they vary from those of an AI engineer
before we move on to what an air
solution architect is if you are an
aspiring AIML engineer then there is no
better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of AI if you are looking
for a course that covers everything from
the fundamental to Advanced Techniques
then accelerate your career in Ai and ml
with our comprehensive postgraduate
program in AI animal both your career
with this AML course delivered in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering
charitability and many more you will
receive a procedure certificate and ask
me anything session by IBM with 5
Capstone and different domains using
real data set you will gain practical
experience master classes by Buddy
University and IBM expert ensure Top
Notch education simply when job assist
help you get noticed by Leading
companies these programs cover
statistics python supervisor and
supervised learning NLP neural network
chargibility Gans and many more skills
admission to this postgraduate program
in AIML course requires two plus years
of work experience preferred a bachelor
degree with an average of 50 percent or
higher marks basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics
enroll now and unlock exciting AIML
opportunities the link is in the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
an AI solution architect AI solution
architect work in the field of
Information Technology to develop and
Implement infrastructure for application
databases and computer network when it
comes to governing and scaling AI effort
they serve as the connecting tissue
between data analysts database
administrator programmers operators and
business unit Executives so moving
forward let's see AI engineer versus AI
solution architect a engineer use
machine learning and neural network for
business AI models they require skills
in software engineering data science and
programming a architect create Advanced
AI infrastructure empathizing with
customer needs to provide solution every
AI Focus Enterprise needs and architect
skills in data analysis AI framework and
infrastructure moving forward let's see
some AI architect responsibilities AI
architect encompasses various
responsibility critical for Designing
and implementing successful artificial
intelligence solution the first one is
system design getting the overall
Architects for AI System including
selecting appropriate Technologies
framework and infrastructure to support
AI models and application the second one
is algorithm selection and development
choosing the right machine learning or
deep learning algorithms and developing
custom algorithms when necessary to
address specific business challenges the
third one is data strategy overseeing
data collection storage pre-processing
and integration to ensure data quality
accessibility and availability for AI
model training and interface
scalability and performance designing AI
system to scale effectively as a data
volumes grow and continuously optimizing
AI models for improved AI accuracy and
efficiency the fifth one is integration
and collaboration collaborating with
cross-functional teams such as data
scientists engineers and business
stakeholders to integrate AI Solutions
seemingly into existing workflows and
align them with organizational objective
so moving forward let's see AI
architecture skills because AI may be
used in such a wide variety of context
and deployed in so many different ways
architects of AI system need to possess
a diversified set of skills that are the
first one are technical skills you need
to be acquainted with the following
technical abilities if you want to have
a successive career as an AI architect
the first one is processes and system
understanding of the processes and
systems that make you of machine
learning and deep learning pipeline the
second one is Mastery of ML and learning
Frameworks like tensorflow and ml
methodologies the third one is
familiarity with sophisticated analytics
tools like scsr and python the fourth
one is awareness of Applied Mathematics
such as neural networks and random
forces technical expertise is necessary
but it is not enough you need to be well
versed in these soft skill so first one
is thought leadership AI Architects
should drive an AI Centric culture
transformation and provide realistic
insights of AI limitation for digital
thought data the second word is
collaborative mindset AI architect
collaborate with various teams and
leaders to ensure AI platform align with
business and Technical goals after
covering AI solution architect skills
let's move forward and see AI architect
salary so there is a possibility that
the salary will very depend on the
company as well as the level of
knowledge and experience that you bring
with you top companies like Nvidia for
Amazon and many more are hiring AI
solution architect in the U.S according
to Glassdoor the average salary for an
AI solution architect is 188 000
annually in the US salary in India the
demand for AI architects in India has
scored the after attention of the major
industry players with renowned companies
such as Wipro Unilever and Infosys and
others actively seeking to these
professionals to add their in their
teams according to Glasgow the national
average salary for an AI solution
architect is 34 lakh per annum annually
in India in conclusion embracing AI
isn't just such Choice it's a strategy
decision that can reshape how your
organization approach machine learning
so accelerate your career in AIML with
our comprehensive professional
certificate course in AI enamel this
machine learning course will equip you
with the highly coveted skills in
machine learning deep learning NLP
generative AI prompt engineering
chargeability and much more through live
classes by industry expert master
classes from IIT kanpur faculty and
Hands-On project you will stay ahead in
the field of year this AIML course
covers Concepts like machine learning
deep learning natural processing
reinforcement learning computer vision
is peace recognition generative ai
explainable ai prompt engineering
charity and much more for admission to
this artificial intelligence course
candidate should have
a bachelor degree with an average of 50
percent of higher Mark preferably two
plus years of formal work experience
prior knowledge of experiences
programming and Mathematics so enroll
now unlock exciting AIML opportunities
so why we're joined now see it's a
feeling for us the course link is in the
description box and pin comment with
that we have come to end of this video
on becoming an AI solution architect I
hope you found it valuable and
entertaining please ask any question
about these topics covered in this video
in the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problem thank you for watching stay safe
and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here